- Today what I'm gonna talk
about is a research paper,
a review article,
talking about the origin
of the new coronavirus
that's wreaking havoc everywhere,
and essentially asking the
question where did it come from?
And as previously mentioned,
this is a review article,
so this is summarizing
around 30 different research
articles from different fields
and different types of research,
and I'm gonna talk about many of those,
but first I just wanted to
give you an introduction to me
and kind of my scientific past.
So I'm originally from
Virginia, and where I grew up,
but after college I moved to New York
and stayed with my grandmother
here in this nice cozy
New York City apartment,
and during that time I also
luckily found a career
in scientific research,
and so over the past 10 years or so
I've been studying and working in a lab,
and so this is, well let
me switch to the pointer,
and so this is me in a lab,
and I typically study
things related to DNA,
and right now I'm studying how
DNA is organized in a cell.
So as you all might know
DNA, it's really long,
so if you took a single cell
and stretched out all the DNA,
it would actually be much taller than me,
about the size of Michael
Jordan it would be,
and all that DNA has to
fit in a very tiny cell,
and it organizes itself in different ways.
And that's what I'm currently studying
at Rockefeller University,
but what I'm curious about also is
how DNA and other genetic
information give rise
to evolution and different traits,
and I'm gonna be talking about that
in light of the viral
evolution of the coronavirus.
Okay so this is me
currently with my partner
in our cozy New York City apartment.
I'm trying to maintain our
mental health by doing some yoga.
I've also been doing some
sewing projects as well,
and I don't know if you all can see this
but there's a cookie inside of this mug.
So we've been doing a lot of baking
and a couple of cookies a day is
also helping keep our spirits
up during these trying times.
Okay so now to the research.
So as the, as Jeanne mentioned,
the name of this research is
called the proximal origin
of SARS-CoV-2, or as I'll refer to it
as the new coronavirus,
and this question that
they're asking is essentially
when did the new Coronavirus,
as pictured in a cartoon here,
become deadly to humans?
And again this is a
correspondence or review article,
but there are still many different authors
from different parts of the world
that have collaborated together to write
and critically think about this topic,
but you also notice something
quiet outstanding here is that
this article has been viewed
4.2, almost 4.3 million times
by different people throughout the world
in a very short time,
and one of the reasons for this is
because of the implications
that this article talks
about is whether or not
this new coronavirus was
a result of bioterrorism,
which has been debunked but,
and their rationale I'll
present to you today,
but also I wanna present
to you the rationale
of where they think it
might have come from
and became deadly to humans.
I also want to kind of
tell you the techniques
that allow us to track genetic changes.
So that's also part of
the goal of this talk,
and I just wanna reemphasize that
even though the authors
didn't do the research,
they did do a lot of,
there are many authors
and they are coming from
different parts of the world,
a couple within the United States
but there is also some in Australia
and in Edinburgh University of UK,
but a lot of the research
has been done in China
but also different parts of the world.
So this is really a collaborative event
and just highlighting that
in science it's such a important
thing to do, cooperate.
So before we get into talking
about the actual research
and the discussion underlying it,
I wanna go over a few key terms.
So I know the central dogma was reviewed
in this series last week,
but I also want to review it just briefly,
and then also I'm gonna be talking
about an important region
of the coronavirus protein
called the receptor-binding domain.
I'll also be talking about
this technique called sequence alignment
and how that is used
to watch the evolution,
how we track the evolution
of the virus through that,
and using this idea of a molecular clock.
Okay so we would have our virus here,
and inside the virus there
is this gene material,
or genome as I might
refer to it sometimes,
and this in the virus is an RNA molecule.
In humans this is a DNA molecule,
but the virus has RNA,
and this material is the founding
material that gets started
and tells it's the information
how to build the cell.
This material then gets
transcribed, essentially copied,
like you would just transcribe a note,
into what we call messenger RNA,
which is just an intermediate stage
that allows the cell to
take this information
and then convert it into protein,
which is a really important part,
and this is called translation,
and the reason this is
called translation is because
it's in some sense a different language,
even though it's directly based off of
this RNA language that it's coming from,
and this language has what we refer to
as different kind of letters
or we refer to it as amino acids.
So these are just abbreviations
for those amino acids.
So you can see that Y-H-T-V-S,
they're just shorthand,
and they're organized in
this kind of linear string,
and these encode for the very
functional parts of the cell,
the proteins that execute the tasks.
So for example you all might have heard
of a spike domain or a spike protein,
and so this is important
for the infectiousness of the virus,
and I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about this protein
in its different domains,
but before that I just
also want to remind you all
that this genetic element
here, the RNA of the virus,
it needs to be able to replicate itself,
and during this replication
this can sometimes cause mutations,
and these mutations
generally happen randomly,
but essentially like making it an error,
and these errors can be propagated
and continued on into the
next virus, passed along.
Okay, so we have our protein words
made out of our amino
acid so-called letters,
but these can be expanded on
just like we can create words
into sentences and give
it more information,
and so for proteins how
this works is that they,
this linear organization
of the amino acids
then can fold into different
structures and shapes
that allow it to give it
different tasks within the cell,
and this can be even more complicated
and give more context
to how this domain works
with different parts or
different domains of a protein
or with different even more proteins.
And so what I'm showing
here this green one
this is actually the
receptor-binding domain
that's found in the coronavirus,
the new coronavirus,
and this domain is really
important for its ability
to interact with cells that
express this ACE-2 receptor.
So these cells include the human lungs
and other different tissues,
but the lungs are one of
the most prevalent one
that express this receptor,
and this receptor-binding
domain, as the name suggests,
helps it bind to the cell
and then allows it eventually to interact
or to enter the cell
and become infectious.
So the way we think about these
different shapes are kind of
like this very classic toy
in which you have shapes
that corresponds to different receptors.
So for example this one
here would fit nicely
in this small hole,
whereas it might fit in these other ones
but it might not be as
snug or as compatible,
so it might fall out more easily.
So that's kind of how we think
about proteins and their shapes
and how that informs different
interactions in the cell.
Okay, and so now the technique
that is most used and talked about
in this research review is
this technique called sequence alignment,
and this can be done with
the RNA sequence, the genes,
but what we're gonna talk
about is just the protein sequence,
and so the goal of this is just,
it's similar to a search
function or a find.
If you wanna find all the
things that are similar,
they don't necessarily have
to be the exact sequence,
but you can see that you
wanna line the sequences up
so that they are most similar.
Even though there are
some differences here.
Yeah, so essentially just finding things
that are similar or related to each other,
and one of the things that
this does is allows us
to identify those amino acids,
those that stay the same,
and those might give us some
insight into the structure
and what kind of structures are important
for the protein to
create different shapes,
but also what things
that the virus might
need to always maintain.
Some other ones that are more
mutated and changed are often
those that can evolve and
take different shapes,
and those also might be important
for understanding the
evolution of the protein
and the virus in general,
and so what we can do is
use this alignment technique
to essentially map the
what we call as a lineage,
but is essentially trying to
understand who came first,
and then who gave rise to the
next one and the next one,
just like we think about
our great grandparents,
our grandparents, and then
all the way down to the child.
So the way this works is essentially
those sequences that are most similar
and those that we think are
the most distant ancestors
or relatives, and then we
look at the difference.
The next one we'll map is the one
that has only a slight difference.
So in this case this S changed to a T,
but otherwise it's the same sequence,
and so this is likely to be the next step
of a mutation that occurred,
but this T is maintained
throughout the rest of these,
is passed on, and then other
mutations can build off
of that and create more changes,
and so this is the way we
track time essentially,
in a genetic, or in a genetic lineage
because proteins are ultimately
coming from the genes.
Okay, so now we reviewed these key terms.
We have the central dogma,
which is essentially going
from genes to proteins,
and these proteins are
functioning in the cell
and have like tasks,
and the one protein domain
that we talked about
of the coronavirus is this
receptor-binding domain,
which is really important for its ability
to interact with some
of the cells in humans,
in the ACE2 receptor,
and then we talked about
the sequence alignment,
which is essentially just
identifying who's related,
who's in the family, who's
coming to the cookout.
The next is a molecular clock
using this sequence alignment
to essentially trace lineage
and see who came first,
who's the intermediate, and
who's the most recent one.
Okay, and because this is a review article
that's encompassing many
different types of research,
I'm just gonna go
over the different styles
of scientific reasoning
because there are many types of ways
to create scientific knowledge.
So one of the first ways
is this categorization
and classification,
and in this paper essentially
what that means is collecting the genes,
the genomes of different viruses, okay.
So sequencing the genes and
compiling them, and then
there's the historical-based
evolutionary reasoning.
So these are different ways of thinking
that have been established
in the evolutionary field
that give us ways to interpret the data
that I'll talk about,
and then lastly there's
this hypothetical modeling,
which is essentially taking
computer math equations
that build off each other
and use different scenarios
to calculate different possible things.
So you've probably heard this
in the context of modeling
for the amount of cases of coronavirus
that are gonna happen in
different populations,
and those can be changing
depending on human behavior.
What I wanted to talk about
is hypothetical modeling
of proteins and the structure of proteins,
but first I just wanna
review that the overall goal
of this study was to determine
how the new coronavirus emerged
and when it became deadly in humans.
Okay so the authors discussed
three possibilities.
So one is that the coronavirus
originated in animals,
and that the current deadly form
to humans originated in
animals and jumped to humans,
and then began to spread
from human to human
and it was already quite deadly.
The alternative hypothesis
is that it began in animals
in a kind of intermediate phase
where it wasn't as deadly,
and it jumped to humans,
and then it passed from human to human,
and that allowed it to
adopt its more deadly form.
And lastly what people have
also talked about is that
it's possible being made in a lab,
and this is largely been debunked
as a form of bioterrorism,
and I'm gonna talk about
the reasons in the paper
that they give for this rationale.
So, but first I want to
talk about this, these,
it's starting in animals,
and so a lot of people have heard
of the coronavirus in
relationship to the bat
because the bats do have
a lot of coronaviruses,
different types, but there's
also this other animal
that I didn't know about
until I started researching for this talk,
and I just wanted to, you
know, step back and take a poll
and see if anybody else
recognizes this animal
and knows, you know, what
kind of animal it is,
or oh this is, you know, really
everybody is really good,
and so the possibilities
are that it's an anteater,
it's an armadillo, it's a
pangolin, or it's super cute,
and a lot of people are nailing it, right.
C is the most accurate.
It's a pangolin, which is a small mammal.
It is also a, okay let me.
I have to, okay, share results, sorry.
I can't get the poll out of here.
- [Facilitator] All
right, I will take it off.
- Okay so, but they are
also super cute too,
so that was also a valid answer.
So I spent a whole afternoon.
Now I can't move to the next slide.
So I spent a whole afternoon looking
at pictures of baby pangolins,
which are essentially
a real life baby Yoda,
and so they're super adorable,
but they also unfortunately
harbor the new,
or relatives of the new coronavirus,
and so how the data
that the research is talking
about was collected was
that the cells from different
animals, including from bats,
so actually from bats, it
was taken from bat droppings,
and the sequences that
most people know from bats
actually come from about seven years ago,
whereas the sequence
that come from pangolins
actually come from very recent.
So within the past few
months there was a pangolin
that died from coronavirus-like symptoms,
and that was in a wildlife refugee,
and they took the cells and
sequenced their material,
their genetic material,
and this has an asterisk here
because sequencing the genetic material
from viruses from animals
is very difficult.
When this genetic material is sequenced,
a lot of it is actually coming
from either the bat or
the pangolin itself.
So very little of it is actually
coming from the viruses,
and thus there is a
really incomplete catalog
of all the viruses that
have been sequenced,
but the ones that have been sequenced,
what we've done with it, or
what they've done with it,
is they've used that to
make sequence alignments
and to determine
how related different
viruses are to each other,
and so the general overview is that
there's a highly-related bat coronavirus.
So 96% to the new coronavirus.
So overall it's very, very similar,
but there's also a pangolin
coronavirus that is 91% similar.
So it's also very highly similar
and it has a really
interesting unique signature
that I'm gonna talk about in a second,
and then the SARS coronavirus,
so this is the 2003,
generally referred to just as SARS.
This is less related, about
80% related okay, and then also
this receptor-binding
domain has the most changes.
Okay, and so the data that they present
in the paper is essentially,
what this is, this pink bar,
is just a cartoon of protein
with all of its amino acids,
and so this is, what they're
showing is the spike protein,
and these numbers refer to the amino acids
that have been in just
right next to each other,
just in this kinda line,
and what you can see are
these blue lines here,
and those are indicating important changes
in this receptor-binding domain,
and so if we zoom in a little
bit closer what you can see is
what they have is the human
SARS-CoV-2, the new coronavirus.
They have the bat coronavirus
that's 96% similar,
and then the pangolin coronavirus,
and the original SARS coronavirus,
and two more distantly related ones,
and so what you can see is
that the bat is very closely
related to the new coronavirus,
but there are some key amino acid changes
that exist between the bat
and the new coronavirus, but,
so this F and this L, this
Q and this Y, this S and R,
and these other ones here,
but these also are found in the pangolin.
So they're actually very very similar
to the ones that are found,
and they are known to be very important
for the binding of the
coronavirus to the ACE2 receptor
that allows it to infect
the lungs and other cells.
So even though the bat
coronavirus is the most related
to this one, the pangolin one has
this really unique signature
that's really important
for the infectiousness.
So this indicates that the new coronavirus
likely comes from a natural source
because of its high identity
to the bat coronavirus
and the signature found in pangolins
that is already existing in nature.
So this is one strong argument
for it not being created in a lab,
and so I'm gonna talk about
just briefly this other site
that you can see that there's
some other important changes,
and this is referred to
as the cleavage site,
and the cleavage site is
just generally important for,
not that binding of the
receptor or the virus protein
to the ACE2 receptor, but
instead the entry into the cell,
but what you can see here is that
this new coronavirus has
this amino acid signature
that none of these,
not the pangolin nor the
bat coronaviruses have.
So this is likely something
that more recently changed,
and this has also been
confirmed in experiments
that it is important
for the infectiousness of
the coronavirus in humans.
Okay, so now it's time
to talk about the
interpretation of this data.
So those are the major findings,
and the question is whether
this virus originated,
the deadliness of this virus originated
in animals or in humans,
and we already talked about
that it's very unlikely,
that it didn't originate in a lab,
but we're gonna do another poll
and see what everyone thinks.
Okay so this one wasn't as
easy as the pangolin question,
and the reason why is I guess
because of that it's
because it's not clear.
So that's one of the reasons why, okay.
Sorry I can't get out of this one as well.
- [Facilitator] Can you just X out?
Oh it stopped sharing, there we go.
- Okay, and so that's one of the reasons
why people often write
review articles is because
there's some unanswered
questions in the field.
So authors suggest that this
receptor-binding domain,
because it's so similar to the one
that's seen in the pangolins,
this part was already
mutated in some animal,
it could've been bats, it
could've been pangolins,
and then jumped to humans,
and it's possible that
this cleavage domain was
already existing then too,
but it's also possible that
it, this cleavage domain,
made those important changes
while transferring to human-to-human.
And the authors say that
more scientific data
could swing the balance
of this in evidence
to favor one hypothesis or the other.
So that means that
there's still an open
window on this question,
and some of the things that
could be used to answer this is
if they find viruses from animals
and that do match it more similar,
that would indicate
this kind of hypothesis.
It could also use sequences of
viruses that come from humans
before that outbreak started,
and that might favor,
that might shift it to this hypothesis.
Okay, and so as we
mentioned this is unlikely,
but we're gonna also talk about
some of the other reasons
the author mentioned that
this is not only unlikely
but it's very unlikely.
Okay so the one thing that
we mentioned previously is that
there's a natural signature.
So from the sequence alignment,
just the uncanny similarity
between those found in nature
really suggests that it is a product
of evolution in humans or in animals,
or starting at least in animals,
but there's also this really
important reason is that
because viruses, they don't, we can't,
it's not very easy to isolate a virus
because there are also
many different viruses
within one cell or one sample,
and so when we isolate
the viruses in the lab,
we often add these DNA signatures to them,
and these DNAs or in this
case it would be RNA, sorry,
but we add these genes to them
that allow us to track them
and manipulate them and
make them very easy,
and otherwise it's really very
difficult to work with those
and edit them or manipulate them in ways
that would be necessary
for a bioterrorism agent.
So all the sequences that have been found
thus far lack any kind of signature
that is found in the lab,
both in humans or in animals.
So none of those exist.
Another reason is using modeling data
for the protein structure
and the interaction
between the receptor-binding
domain and the ACE2 receptor.
So what researchers found
out is that the structure
and the shapes of the
receptor-binding domain
that are found in the new coronavirus,
even though they are very
infectious and make everyone sick,
they're more like taking
one of these little circles
and putting it in this big hole
where it doesn't really fit.
It can fit there but it's not really snug,
and so they suggest if that
somebody were to create
a bioterrorism agent
they would create something
that is more snuggly fit,
more efficient at doing its job
and becoming more infectious.
Okay, and so the general conclusions are
that the new coronavirus has a signature
that's occurring in nature.
It has the highest sequence
similarity to a virus found in bats.
It has a receptor-binding
domain signature of a virus
that's found in pangolins,
and this is quite recent,
this virus, infecting in the pangolin.
It has a cleavage site
that's also important for its function,
but this is more recent and
it's not clear in what organ,
in what animal or in humans it originated.
Okay and then also the
receptor-binding domain is
not optimized to bind for
the human ACE2 receptor,
suggesting that it's not engineered,
and it also lacks any
signature of loud engineering.
Okay, and just to review,
this paper used a couple
of different methods.
It used the categorization
and classification.
So that's essentially taking and sampling
as many virus genes or genomes
that we could find in nature,
and one thing to note about this is that
we don't have a complete
collection of all the genes
and genomes of viruses
found in different animals.
So there might be some that come to light
that change our interpretations of this.
Okay, so there's
also historical-based evolutionary
reasoning that we used,
and one thing to note is
determining the original ancestor.
So this is often difficult,
mostly because of this
incompleteness of the genomes,
and so this is something that
researchers are still trying
to do is determine the
original most recent ancestor
of this virus.
And then these hypothetical
models that I talked about,
the protein structure not being optimal.
These are being confirmed in living cells
in using these models
to predict those different
more efficient structures
and a lot of these,
a lot of what is known
from the predictions are
turning out to be accurate.
Okay, and so why is this kind
of question important other
than knowing that it wasn't
an act of bioterrorism.
This research can help
in many different ways.
So we can know for example
which animals can be hosts to the virus.
So this could prevent future transfers
of the virus from animals to humans,
but it also could help
us stop spreading the virus in animals.
So that might be important way
to stop spreading the virus,
but we can also track
using the same techniques
to track the ongoing
evolution of the virus,
and we can essentially look
how the virus is being transmitted
from one population to
another using the same kind
of techniques of this sequence alignment.
And then lastly these protein models can
also help give us information
about what areas of the protein to target
when we create drugs or vaccines,
and so that's also very
important to think about.